wir haben eine klimakatastrophe und
machen einfach so weiter wie bisher
wachstum wachstum wachstum ist nicht
alle mehr verzichten oder reicht es wenn
wir mehr in nachhaltige technologien
investieren deutschrock wie retten wir
den planeten wachstum oder verzicht
rasen wir in den abgrund
[Musik]
über jahrzehnte hat uns wachstum
wohlstand beschert jetzt aber wehrt sich
unser planet
grüne energie nachhaltige mobilität und
innovation sollen uns helfen
aber reicht das
wir haben keine zeit mehr dort
wissenschaft haben wir drei vier jahre
wir treffen gründer die mit neuen
technologien das klima retten wollen
warum kann ich denn im moment nicht co2
neutral bleiben das war einfach mein
traum dass wir das heute schon geschafft
haben oder müssen wir unser leben ganz
neu denken um den planeten zu retten
wir haben ja eigentlich schon alles ist
ja nicht so dass wir noch irgendwelche
krassen maschinen erfinden müssen
[Musik]
tust du denn irgendwas um die welt zu
retten ja ich wohne zum beispiel in
einem niedrigenergiehaus mit der
wärmepumpe und solaranlage auf dem dach
hat übrigens auch sinnvoller ist der
gaspreis irgendwann regal sein kann na
ja das finde ich cool finde ich auch gut
dass du das machst du dich ich muss
sagen ich als mutter in einer kleinen
wohnung in berlin ja das ist irgendwie
nicht so die möglichkeit für mich
allerdings klar wir haben kein auto wer
isst kein fleisch also wir benutzen den
öpnv ausfahrt los geht man also insofern
halbwegs klimafreundlich aber wenn jetzt
jemand auf mich zukommen würde und sagen
würde du machst nicht genug fürs klima
würde ich sagen ja
ja das trifft aber immer auf uns alle zu
also wenn du in deutschland lebst du
bist du zwangsläufig mit in der
verantwortung weil deutschland ist auf
platz vier der liste der länder die am
meisten co2 ausgestoßen haben
historische platz vier das war mir nicht
klar krasse also das was getan werden
muss es glaube ich allen klar die frage
ist nur wer geht wirklich aus seiner
komfortzone heraus wie weit geht man
berlin kurz vor acht uhr morgens ich
bekomme einen tipp das aktivistinnen
bündnis letzte generation plant eine
blockade fordert verzicht und will
aufrütteln fürs klima eine minute
nachdem ich da bin geht alles ganz
schnell
[Musik]
nichts geht mehr die kreuzung
frankfurter tor dicht die wichtigste
verkehrsader berlins aus richtung osten
blockiert keine kommen wir vorbei am
thema klima
was machte hier und was möchtet ihr ja
wir sitzen hier weil wir von der
bundesregierung unter olaf scholz
fordern dass es keinen weiteren ausbau
von faszien strukturen insbesondere kein
neues nordseeöl geben wird die letzte
generation hat es auch schon direkt
versucht die diskussion mit dem
damaligen kanzlerkandidaten und die
jetzigen bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat
die klima aktivistinnen nicht zufrieden
gestellt jetzt wird geklebt fürs klima
viele empfinden das als nötigung spüren
blanke wut
nur die ganze gesellschaft in haftung
genommen
bei ein paar leute meinen sie müssen die
welt
manche ergreifen auch partei für die
letzte generation
für die zukunft
etwas macht dann hast du manchmal angst
dass irgendwelche autofahrer innen
ausrasten und euch vielleicht überfahren
aufs gas drücken und losfahren also die
angst ist immer da das ist ja auch ein
risiko dass ich hier eingehen und das
macht auch keinen spaß hier zu sitzen
andererseits ist es eben viel viel
belastender zu wissen dass ich in zwei
bis drei jahren vor einer welt stehen
der die kipp punkte schon losgetreten
worden und ich nichts mehr dagegen tun
kann es tut mir natürlich auch leid für
die anderen menschen ich verstehe das
aber wir müssen auch sagen dass die
menschen die da gerade im verkehr sitzen
die sind die später potenziell kein
essen haben die ihre kinder nicht mehr
ernähren können oder der ihr haus in
einer flut kaputt geht und ich glaube
das sind die sachen die wir jetzt ganz
klar angehen müssen und so wir was
verändern müssen die polizei hat schon
routine es ist eine von über 100
blockaden der letzten generation
bundesweit in diesem jahr mit
sonnenblumenöl werden die fest geklebten
hände von der straße gelöst zwei stunden
lang geht nichts
davon hat cdu generalsekretär mario
czaja genug er fordert genau wie
hooligans sollten auch blockierer schon
vor angekündigten aktionen konsequent
und so lange wie möglich im präventiven
gewahrsam genommen werden
abschreckung statt dialog mit dem wild
entschlossen
ich habe vor kurzem meinen job
aufgegeben ich bin energieeffizienz
berater und studierter hydrogeologe und
deswegen ist das ein arbeitstag
unbezahlter arbeitstag aber trotzdem ist
die wichtigste arbeit die ich nach
meinem gewissen zu diesem zeitpunkt
machen könnte empfindest du das was du
hier machst heute und deine arbeit mit
dieser aktion als eine art verzicht
verzicht persönlich aber natürlich ich
muss meine 80 jährige mutter fragen ob
sie mit der hypothek hilft also da ist
jede menge verzichtbar das belastet
meine beziehung mit meiner ehefrau
mit freunden zum teil mit
arbeitskollegen sowieso jetzt er also da
ist alles viel verzichtbar aber
letztendlich ist es keine wahl wenn es
um unser überleben gibt geht dann dann
muss man manchmal auch auf das
verzichten auch auf seine bequemlichkeit
ja also das war mich echt spannend zu
sehen auch wie sehr die für ihre sache
brennen auch die bandbreite der
reaktionen fand ich echt krass man kann
auch beide standpunkte im nachvollziehen
die einen müssen halt zur arbeit und die
anderen wollen dass ich schleunigst was
ändert
den meisten menschen ist bewusst dass
sich etwas ändern muss laut einer
umfrage der vereinten nationen halten 77
prozent der deutschen den klimawandel
für einen globalen notfall nur wie der
in den griff zu bekommen ist da gehen
die meinungen weit auseinander
es brodelt in der heimat des autors seit
erstem januar 2019 gilt etwa in
stuttgart ein fahrverbot für ältere
dieselmodelle und jetzt will die eu ab
2035 dem verkauf neuer autos mit benzin-
oder dieselmotoren sogenannten
verbrennern ganz verlieren das sorgt für
unsicherheit in der welt autofahrer
norbert haug war in zwei jahrzehnten als
mercedes motorsportchef mehrmals formel
1 weltmeister inzwischen berät
mittelständische firmen und kämpft für
die zukunft des verbrennungsmotors ich
bin bei verboten generell nicht so sehr
zu begeistern und ich glaube wir müssen
wissen hier wird auto gefahren um den
verkehrsminister zu ärgern sondern hier
wird gefahren weil damit geld verdient
wird weil damit steuern verdient werden
der verbrenner ist ein auslaufmodell
weil e autos umweltfreundlicher und
effizienter sind bei elektromotoren
kommen 70 bis 90 prozent der
eingesetzten energie am rad an rad
brenner motoren 20 bis maximal 50
prozent und natürlich sollen e-autos
aufsicht mit reinem ökostrom fahren doch
die umstellung auf e mobilität bei
weltweit 1,4 milliarden verbrennen autos
wird dauern
die dualität so wie wir im moment haben
es vielleicht gar nicht mehr der weg für
die zukunft eine absolut bin ich der
erste der das vertritt und verteidigten
übrigens auch praktiziert aber busse
fahren rad ja ja klar aber busfahren ist
auch nicht immer herrlich ich bin
überhaupt nicht gegen muss sagen ich
will überhaupt nicht gegen radfahren
aber man muss die gefahren erkennen im
mischverkehr rad zu fahren ist
gefährlicher als formel 1 rennen zu
fahren dass wir auch wissen
aus seinem diesel will haug nicht
verzichten solange es zu wenig ökostrom
gibt hält e autos für keine alternative
der verbrenner ist nicht das problem
dass das verbrennt verbrennt ist das
problem nämlich fossiler kraftstoff und
hätten wir schon längst synthetische
kraftstoffe
dann wären wir annähernd klimaneutral
unterwegs für diese synthetischen
kraftstoffe die fuels setzt sich auch
die fdp ein und damit gegen das
verbrenner verbot enthüllungen über
absprachen dazu zwischen finanzminister
lindner und dem künftigen vw chef blumen
gießen jüngstes netz heiß laufen denn
eigentlich gilt beim auto die e
mobilität als lösung da es viel energie
brauchen
wir fahren zu einem zulieferer den haupt
berät dessen ingenieure mit innovationen
autos sparsamer machen früher nur beim
sprit heute auch beim stromverbrauch sei
die umstellung auf elektromobilität für
uns eigentlich ein schritt in richtung
also der nehmen oder oh da gibt es jetzt
ganz viele kompetenzen die wir haben die
wir zukünftig mehr gebraucht wir haben
natürlich erstmal sehr viel arbeit durch
die ganze neuen antriebsarten und aber
trotzdem wird der verbrennungsmotor nach
unserem empfinden als ingenieure die
sich mit vielerlei konzept beschäftigen
in ganz ganz vielen teilen der welt und
auch ein ganz ganz vielen fahrzeugtypen
bleiben zum beispiel
agrarmaschinen baumaschinen
notstromaggregate
langstrecken fahrzeuge fahrzeuge die
eingesetzt werden zu niedrigpreisen wo
ich einfach dieses geld nicht habe
währung um diese infrastruktur für die
elektrizität nachhaltigkeit fängt damit
an bestehen das nicht sinnlos
wegzuwerfen sondern weiter zu verwenden
und den verbrenner motor da wo es sinn
macht mit synthetischem kraftstoff
bedienen das schließt nicht aus die
elektrifizierung dort wo sie
funktioniert verzicht muss man sich
leisten können und ich glaube ein gutes
oder sozial motto gute einkommen bei den
leuten und verzicht und freiwilliger
verzicht bin ich sehr dafür
[Musik]
so richtig überraschen war das jetzt
nicht was die beiden gesagt haben aber
es ist schon richtig dass es eben nicht
für alle transportprobleme eine
patentlösung mit genau und mit dem
freiwilligen verzicht das alles auch
leichter gesagt als getan
fliegst du noch fährst du noch nur wenn
es wirklich nicht anders geht und wenn
ich fliegen muss bezahlen sie nur 2
ausgleich aber mein transportmittel oder
einer stadt ist ein elektro roller der
mal darauf legt okay ganz so krass bin
ich mich also ich fliege schon auch
manchmal noch alle paar jubeljahre aber
wenn ich sehe dass so superreiche wie
kylie jenner ihren privatjet nehmen für
eine strecke was eigentlich 40
autominuten gewesen werden also ich bin
nicht das problem
vielleicht geht fliegen ja irgendwann
klimaneutral in karlsruhe arbeitet die
firma in ihrer tag an der entwicklung
von if you es den co2 neutralen
kraftstoff verbrennt
wie das geht und vor allem wann das geht
will ich vom gründerteam bild gemacht
also das ist eine anlage in der jetzt
schon
produziert werden genau
kraftstoff aus wasser wind und sonne
klingt fantastisch der chemische prozess
ist einfach aus wasser wird mit grünem
strom der aus sonne und wind gewonnen
wird wasserstoff
diesem wasserstoff wird dann co2
zugesetzt das sonst als abgas in die
atmosphäre geblasen werden würde zum
beispiel bei der zementherstellung
und dann kommt das raus klimaneutraler
kraftstoff der in allen
verbrennungsmotoren eingesetzt werden
kann
andrea
und nach tequila
was sind die drei wichtigsten
anwendungsfelder die man jetzt als
erstes sieht wo man sagt da werden wir
das zeug auf jeden fall braucht einmal
ist das natürlich die flugindustrie die
keine möglichkeit hat insbesondere auf
den langstreckenflug auf batterie
elektrisch oder auch in näherer oder
entfernten zukunft auf wasserstoff
umzustellen der zweite ist ganz klar die
schifffahrt weil auch dort große schwere
batterien absolut keinen sinn machen in
der dritte faktor ist die chemische
industrie warum kann ich denn im moment
nicht co2 neutral fügen das wäre einfach
mein traum dass wir das heute schon
geschafft haben aber wir haben jetzt
gerade mal gezeigt dass die technologie
funktioniert und jetzt ist es wie mit
allem was hat wales wir müssen jetzt im
markthochlauf schaffen wir wollen der
erste sein der schaft im jahr 2035 bis
zu fünf prozent des gegenwärtigen
europäischen ölbedarfs über diese
synthetischen ihr viel zu ersetzen
mehrere firmen versuchen das aber die
herstellung von ips braucht sehr viel
energie deshalb setzt die industrie beim
auto auf e mobilität
denn im vergleich zur direkten
stromeinspeisung bei einem e motor
braucht ein mit eve us- angetriebener
verbrenner das sechs bis siebenfache an
energie die großen mengen grünen strom
sollen in wind und sonnenreichen
gebieten weltweit gewonnen werden die
produktion läuft aber erst an deshalb
ist der grüne sprit etwa doppelt so
teuer wie fossile treibstoffe dass
fossile rohöl ist immer noch viel zu
billig wenn man sieht was das einfach
für folgeschäden anrichten
nichtsdestotrotz sehen wir dass die
projekte kommen wo wir sehr sehr
günstigen grünstrom haben und die
maßgabe wird sein dass wir im jahr 2030
bei ungefähr 1 euro pro liter an
produktionskosten aber im moment wer ist
eigentlich für ihr geschäftsmodell gut
wenn man einfach richtig ordentlich hohe
co2 steuer hätte ganz genau je teurer
der fossilen rohstoff wird und je höher
die co2 abgabe wird desto größere
chancen haben auch diese co2 neutralen
produkte sich am markt durchzusetzen
und dazu ist politischer wille einfach
oder ausreichende regulierung durch die
politik kommt in ihrer tags innovation
nur schleppend voran ein container
zukunft mehr noch nicht
und auch anderswo stößt der grüne
fortschritt auf widerstand grünheide
brandenburg hier hat tesla seine giga
factory gebaute autos made in germany
angeschoben durch den zweitreichsten
mann der welt des labors in der maske
[Musik]
der blanke hohn für manuela heuer und
die menschen von der bürgerinitiative
grünheide für sie der preis für die
natur viel zu hoch denn viele hektar
wald mussten weichen
ich sage mal das ist die größte oder ist
eine große umweltkatastrophe was hier
passiert weil dieser wald ist ein co2
speicher das wissen alle und es wird
aber weit abgeholzt ohne ende ich merke
das richtig nur ihr seid richtig
aufgebracht glaubt ihr dass ihr euch
auch so auf regelt dass ihr so verletzt
wert auf eine art aus von der politik
wenn es sich jetzt dabei um ein
einkaufszentrum oder um wohngebiet
handeln würde was hier gebaut werden
würde es geht grundsätzlich darum dass
hier die natur zerstört wird und das ist
egal was dann gebaut wird okay was aber
jetzt hier nochmal hinzukommt ist das
hier eine chemiefabrik ist auch die
batterie verbringen treten steht in
einem trinkwasserschutzgebiet und das
ist für uns das rüstet emotionale
tesla benötigt große mengen an
grundwasser für die produktion und das
in einer der trockensten regionen
deutschlands hier kommt nur halb so viel
regen vom himmel wie etwa in münchen
dementsprechend begrenzt die
grundwassermenge das ist auch das was
wir wussten und auch gesagt haben
dass die mengen die dort gebraucht
werden für die produktion das was wir
zur verfügung stellen können übersteigen
werden gerne hätten wir auch mit dem
bürgermeister von grünheide gesprochen
doch der hatte keine zeit für ein
interview für die politik das argument
für tesla bis zu 12.000 neue
arbeitsplätze im strukturschwachen
brandenburg in berlin und brandenburg
liegt die arbeitslosigkeit mit 8,2
prozent deutlich über dem
bundesdurchschnitt etwa 5000 jobs sind
schon geschaffen worden
wachstum wohlstand und ein bisschen elon
musk der star der grünen mobilität in
brandenburg wer will da über wasser
sprechen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
elektroautos sind für viele der
schlüssel zur grünen mobilität und
irgendwo müssen die batterie autos eben
gebaut werden tesla hat sich zudem
verpflichtet wälder wieder aufzuforsten
jetzt will ich aber sagen ihr seid alle
menschen die auf jeden fall für die
umwelt sind und ich würde wahrscheinlich
auch sagen die sagen dass
klimakatastrophe auf jeden fall sehr
akut ist nicht okay
was können wir denn machen in sachen
mobilität was nachhaltig ist und was dem
planeten wirklich hilft was wären so
eure vorschläge ideen wir müssen unsere
ganze mobilität umdenken sie sind ja
immer noch der meinung dass einzel
mobilität das heißt jeder hat ein auto
jeder ist irgendwie mobil hessler ist
für mich auch immer so einen
luxusgegenstand warum muss das von null
auf hundert in soundsoviel sekunden das
jetzt teil unnötig eigentlich wenn man
die nach dem nachhaltigkeitsgedanken mal
richtig verstanden hat das geld was da
jetzt investiert wurde vielleicht auch
vom vom von der region sollte vielmehr
in diese nahverkehr gehen in solche
carsharing option offen dorf ja
vielleicht auch dass man sein eigenes
auto besser teilt oder so also das finde
ich nachhaltig innovation geht eben auch
nicht ohne klimachef das ist ein
grundlegendes problem findet auch der
schweizer ökonom mathias binswanger
auf einem endlichen planeten der sein
unendliches wachstum nicht möglich sei
dass dieses wachstum auf
abwärtsspirale zu entlassungen die
arbeitslosigkeit nimmt zu der konsum
geht zurück und um das zu vermeiden
muss die wirtschaft eben längerfristig
dauernd weiter wachsen und das ist
eigentlich das grundlegende dilemma
wie ist es denn mit so genannten grünen
wachstum also es ist auch immer die rede
davon dass man ressourcenverbrauch und
wachstum voneinander entkoppelt geht das
die frage ist jetzt wie realistisch eine
solche vision tatsächlich ist weil
natürlich können wir zum beispiel jetzt
alles auf elektromobilität umstellen
also die elektrizität die muss dann aus
erneuerbaren energiequellen stammen dazu
müssen diese massiv ausgebaut werden der
verlagern dann letztlich das problem
anders sehen wir haben da nicht ein
wirklich
völlig problemfrei verkehr der keine
emissionen verursacht das ist eine
illusion
okay das klingt jetzt auch nicht
wirklich tröstlich aber irgendwo müssen
wir eben anfangen bestimmt im
individuellen verzicht aber wir brauchen
eben auch technische innovationen
darauf will luise strothmann mich traten
sie handel schon jetzt den einkauf für
fünf macht louise mit dem fahrrad aus
überzeugung
hallo
ein auto hat die familie nicht dass auf
dem land ist das eigentlich als einer
woche einkauf oder weniger als eine
woche weniger der ok ich helfe dir
einfach mal kurz ja wenn du magst gerne
vor anderthalb jahren ist luise mit mann
und drei kleinen kindern von berlin
kreuzberg nach brandenburg gezogen
mitten in den wald alle wege werden
seither per fahrrad erledigt bei wind
und wetter zum beispiel eine stunde
strampeln für einmal einkaufen beim
nächsten großen supermarkt insgesamt
würde ich was wir hier machen nicht
verzichten wir haben halt einfach einen
anderen lebensstil also wir haben uns
einfach für was anderes entschieden und
das hat vor und nachteile
es hat den vorteil dass ich viel mehr an
der frischen luft bin und damit meine
ich sozusagen so richtig frische luft
bist du diese berliner ich fahre fahrrad
hinter den autoabgasen
luisa arbeitet als journalistin in
berlin macht karriere bei einer großen
tageszeitung mit home office und strickt
derzeit disziplin schafft sie ist das
leben auf dem land mit ihren kindern und
die karriere unter einen hut zu bekommen
[Musik]
für meine kinder ist es im moment noch
eher was spannendes wie machen es so in
der familie hat man ja auch zu sachen
die einen so zusammenbinden so bestimmte
dinge wie essen im markt ist und würde
irgendwas besonderes und es fällt er in
diese kategorie luises erkenntnis
klimafreundlich geht mit einfachen
das ist ja genau das ding mit diesen
ganzen lösungen für die klimakrise wir
haben ja eigentlich schon alles ist ja
nicht so dass wir noch irgendwelche
krassen maschinen erfinden müssen gibt
es momente wo durch schon mal dabei
ertappt hast du es zu bereuen hergezogen
zu sein
ich habe es noch nie bereut aber es gab
schon scheiß moment so ein morgen im
januar wo es so bleibt - allrad ist und
es regnet und du weißt du musst jetzt
mit dem fahrrad mit diesen kindern durch
den dunklen wald zur poststelle weil es
nicht anders geht als zeit einfach so
ist und da sitzt du daran denkst oh man
was für ein scheiß machen wir hier
eigentlich
und dann machst du es halt und am
nächsten tag scheint die sonne und du
freust dich total dass die luft so nach
schnee liegt oder dass man irgendwie so
dinge mit bekommt die man im auto nie
mitbekommen würde und dann das ist halt
auch wieder okay oder du kannst einfach
so am wegesrand auch meine kirche
pflücken wie du es gemacht heißt also es
gibt auch viele glücksmomente in deinem
alltag mit fahrt ja total ich denke
schon dass bin dass ich also in gewissem
sinne auch eine verantwortung habe für
die zukunft meiner kinder und für die
welt im allgemeinen
ich glaube aber nicht dass der beste weg
dahin zu kommen ist so
ganz penibel auf andere menschen zu
sagen du darfst das nicht machen du hast
das ich dachte du darfst das nicht
machen sondern eben eher zu überlegen
das vielleicht was was kann ich denn
vorleben was möglich ist und dabei
trotzdem irgendwie entspannt zu bleiben
und nicht durch zu treten
ja das war nicht echt cool wenn luise
die ist einfach so für sich hat sie das
entschieden ist sehr undogmatisch in der
sache gewesen und das hat mich dann
wirklich auch inspiriert noch mal bei
mir selber nach zu gucken was könnte ich
noch anders machen übrigens
interessantes detail in dem zusammenhang
weißt du wer den co2 fußabdruck den
individuellen erfunden hat das war bp
das ist eine strategische maßnahme der
mineralölkonzerne gewesen die
verantwortung zu individuum hin zu
verlagern viele denken gar nicht daran
die verantwortung zu übernehmen zum
ferienstart in nordrhein-westfalen
rennen touristen dem flughafen
düsseldorf die türen ein klimawandel
urlaub muss schon sein ein bisschen weil
eine busreise wären jetzt 17 stunde
unterwegs gewesen also ich habe
zwischendurch darüber nachgedacht ob man
nicht auch anders in urlaub fahren
könnte aber man kommt dann ja nicht in
die richtig fahren gebiete wie mallorca
dabei ist fliegen richtig schlecht fürs
klima eine reise in die usa
beispielsweise verursacht etwa ein
viertel des jahresverbrauchs an co2
eines durchschnittsdeutschen und
kompensieren möchten dass viele reisende
nicht
kompensations geschichten was man da ein
bisschen zusätzliches geld für wird
halte ich für augenwischerei
das finde ich nicht folgen für diesen
flug jetzt nicht nein aber das habe ich
schon mal letztes jahr gemacht habe
nicht so ein schlechtes gewissen
weil ich persönlich ganz ganz ganz lange
darauf verzichtet habe gross zu reisen
ich habe keine flug starben
tatsächlich steigen die fluggastzahlen
in deutschland wieder richtung vor
corona niveau bei interkontinentalflügen
liegt das passagieraufkommen bei 78
prozent im vergleich zum sommer 2009 10
bei europäischen flügen bei etwa 69
einzig die innerdeutschen verbindungen
sind rückläufig hier fliegen nur noch
etwa halb so viele passagiere wie vor
der krise
für den umwelt psychologen gerhard reese
ist der flug verzicht fürs klima ein
kopfproblem warum soll ich jetzt auf
meinen flug verzichten
wenn den 50 jahre nix passiert dass wir
sagen du kannst mit ein co2 fußabdruck
was verändern das wird als barriere
wahrgenommen unterdessen problem weil
das von diesen systemischen lösungen
ablenkt was wir als gemeinschaft was wir
als nachbarschaft als community als
andrew als stadt eigentlich verändern
können wir dass das in die hebel große
lösungen sind gefragt
wie schwer diese durchzusetzen sind sehe
ich in frankfurt hier baut die fraport
ag die mehrheitlich dem land hessen und
den stadtwerken frankfurt gehört das
terminal 3 die erweiterung des größten
deutschen folk moden soll bis 2045 alles
klimaneutral sein mit stromsparenden led
leuchten investitionen in photovoltaik
und windkraft aber das fliegen an sich
bleibt mittelfristig eine große
umweltbelastung 4 milliarden euro kostet
das neue terminal der bau wird trotz
massiver proteste durchgezogen
mitgetragen wird das projekt vom
hessischen wirtschaftsminister tarek al
wazir von den grünen der vor seiner wahl
noch versprochen hatte das projekt
verhindern so wurde das terminal 3 des
frankfurter flughafens raders
ökologisch sinnvoll das zubauen ich habe
in den letzten jahren einiges getan um
die fraport davon zu überzeugen dass man
vielleicht erst mal den bau verschiebt
und anderes macht sie hat sich nicht
darauf eingelassen das war ihr gutes
recht weil sie sozusagen die
baugenehmigung in der hand hatte wir
sehen aber an diesem schnellen hochlauf
des luftverkehrs in diesem sommer der ja
wieder für andere probleme sorgt dass
die menschen weiterhin fliegen fliegen
wollen wir müssen den flugverkehr
eigentlich auf das reduzieren wo er
nicht substituiert wohl nicht ersetzt
werden kann und das sind die
interkontinentalflüge und das müssen wir
effizient machen und in letzter
konsequenz dann eben auch mit ios also
mit klimaneutralen treibstoffen jetzt
gibt ja leute die sagen
wirtschaftswachstum an sich ist ein
irrweg was halten sie darf also es kann
sein dass man in bestimmten bereichen
von entwickelten gesellschafter ein
punkt kommt wo man sagt ein immer mehr
macht keinen sinn ich bin auch sicher
dass dieses immer mehr auch nicht immer
glücklicher macht vielleicht ist ein
wanderwochenende im taunus oder im
odenwald sehr viel besser für die
menschen als einen shopping wochenende
in new york mailand oder london vom
flugzeug hinfliegt wie gehen sie denn
persönlich damit sagen dass sie
sozusagen immer wieder dinge tun müssen
politisch und mittragen müssen die
eigentlich ihrer grund vorstellung davon
wie es gehen müsste diametral
widersprechen
indem ich versuche menschen zu
überzeugen dass es in die richtige
richtung geht wir müssen am ende für das
was wir tun mehrheiten gewinnen und das
bedeutet kompromiss
also für mich ist eine sache klar
geworden nur mit verboten und verzichtet
wird es nicht klappen
aber ganz ohne regulierungen wird auch
nicht klar ist auch klar es ist
natürlich auch so jetzt ist uns
jahrzehnte den ball gebracht worden kauf
ein auto reist um die welt und dann
genau genau so ein mensch wenn ich bin
so ein richtiges konsum opfer obwohl ich
tief innen drin reis es wird mich nicht
nachhaltig glücklich machen das sagt uns
auch die psychologie man kann sich nicht
glücklich kaufen wahrscheinlich aber
auch nicht glücklich hat sich ja das ist
die frage also die frage ist ob verzicht
überhaupt die richtige kategorie ist
vielleicht brauchen wir aber eine neue
definition davon was das gute leben
wirklich ist wie seht ihr das unter dem
hashtag grauzone könnt ihr mit
diskutieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]